sir I just a killer
I'm Maximo from FX guide.com for Wired
this weekend Tatiana maslany is up for
an Emmy for Outstanding Lead Actress in
a Drama Series for her work on the BBC
America show orphan black for four
seasons she's played Sarah Manning and
about ten of her clone sisters and it's
a remarkable piece of acting performance
and of course it works in part because
of the visual effects team that you work
so closely with at intelligent creatures
headed by Jeff Scott for this special
Emmy episode we thought we'd break down
just how tatiana goes about doing one of
these major sequences each sequence
there's normally a VFX tour de force of
some kind at the end of show some real
clone on clone action and this season it
was between Sarah and her evil clone
Rachel Tatyana works with an acting
scene partner Catherine Alexander to
produce these really complicated
sequences writers write a scene it gets
storyboard it mainly from overhead and
then they have a walkthrough with the
director DOP and just some standards
only one they've worked that out do they
bring in Tatiana and her acting double
Catherine and of course any other actors
in the scene the actors then try and
work out - how to use the space inside
the kind of rough constraints that Jeff
and the team have set up as a framework
then they come back the next day and
they film it when Tatiana is moving
between roles the change over time is
really limited by hair and makeup so
Cosima - Helene OH is about the worst at
an hour and a half whereas Sarah -
Alison is down to just a mere 20 minutes
here the transition between Sarah and
Rachel well might seem simple actually
took over an hour because there was a
lot of things happening in this sequence
rather than constantly adding blood to
Sarah's face the guys that intelligent
creatures decided to have just three
different levels of blood makeup and
then in post they did a heel and reveal
by using face tracking to actually
animate the blood flow on her face the
knife in the leg was one of four
different knives on set either a real
knife a half knife or rubber knife etc
but in the end all of those knives were
replaced with a digital knife to give it
real shot-to-shot consistency the team
always likes to shoot the entire
sequence perfectly sold so the editor
can actually
cut and use any particular part they
want whatever the drama requires
although here the editor actually
required even more and asked for the
team to go back so a second unit went
back a couple of weeks later for pickup
shots the sequence was hard as rachel is
crawling all over Sarah oh and a couple
of other aspects they don't use blue
screen so it all had to be rode and in
addition to that there are a whole lot
of lights that they couldn't move
because matching lighting is incredibly
important between the Sarah and Rachel
takes or whatever they set up they had
to stay with and then remove in post in
this past season the intelligent
creatures team did two and a half times
as many effect shots as they did back in
season one some 750 shots but it's
actually the season two finale the
so-called cloned dance party that wins
the award for the most number of
man-hours they actually are quite 5000
now now that's about a team of twelve
people for a month for just two minutes
of screen time
perhaps a close second to that would be
the dinner party finale from season 3 oh
wow mmm everybody really quite Pacific
this is a compliment oh and if you're
looking for some tricks in that scene
nearly all the chairs were glued to the
floor and if you look really carefully
you might count a few more wine glasses
than might perhaps be needed that's
because glasses were added in post to
hide composites in the epigenetic
implications themselves are just
mind-blowing it's rare to see any actor
or actress producing such a range of
performances as tatiana does in orphan
black and thanks to the visual effects
team it's almost impossible to watch her
and not think you're looking at a set of
completely different actors instead of
just one young extremely hard working
actress well don't forget please
subscribe for more behind the scenes
action I'm like see more for why I'm the
chosen loser
you